Нинішню війну називають війною дронів. Як до неї підготувалася Україна?
Зараз наші виробничі потужності - це один комплекс на тиждень.
Які дрони виробляє Росія?
Все іноземне, все скомпоноване. Ось кнопка - Bosch, наприклад. Кнопка запуска.
Чи є в України власний "шахед"?
А чому ми думаємо, що його немає?
І яких "пташок" бракує ЗСУ?
Та кількість - це, знаєте, чайна ложка.  А нам потрібно їх виливати як з відра.
DW поспілкувалася з військовими, урядовцями, виробниками БПЛА,
аби дослідити армію українських дронів.
Це одні з найпопулярніших безпілотників у ЗСУ - SHARK.
Його розробник - приватна компанія Ukrspecsystems.
SHARK - розвідувальний безпілотник. Він має якісну камеру і дальність польоту 80 кілометрів.
Цей БПЛА з'явився вже після початку повномасштабного вторгнення.
Відтоді, як заявляє компанія-розробник, виробництво цих дронів зросло в сотні разів.
"Шарки" часто працюють в парі з "Хаймарсами", наводять і корегують вогонь артилерії.
Виробник "Шарків" каже: у 2022 році з'явився значний запит від військових саме на дрони-розвідники,
тому менше ніж за рік БПЛА вже пройшов випробування.
На момент початку повномасштабного вторгнення безпілотники в Україні виготовляли  сім компаній.
Нині таких виробників майже двісті.
Ми зараз на одному з таких підприємств, яке виготовляє українські дрони.
До 2014 року ця компанія виготовляла тренувальні літаки.
У 2016 році вона випробувала свій безпілотний комплекс - Raybird-3.
З 2018 року комплекс надають ЗСУ.
З повномасштабного вторгнення основне, що змінилося - наші розробки стали набагато жвавішими.
Те, що ми до 2022 року могли розробляти впродовж одного року, якісь зміни,
то зараз ми це маємо робити за декілька тижнів.
Raybird-3, або у військовій версії - ACS-3 - розвідувальний безпілотник.
Його основні переваги, як каже виробник: летить далеко і довго.
Дальність зв'язку: 100-120 км, тривалість польоту - більше, ніж доба.
Raybird-3 може працювати бачити склади і командні пункти глибоко в тилу ворога.
Зараз наші виробничі потужності - це один комплекс на тиждень.
У стандартний комплекс входять три літаки, система запуску - катапульта,
дві наземні станції, блок антен і комплект запасних частин.
До злету готується ще одна українська "пташка" - "Лелека-100".
Це - один з наймасовіших українських безпілотників.
"Лелека" також може вести глибоку розвідку. Дальність польоту - 50 кілометрів.
Вони хороші тим, що їх практично не бачить ворожа ППО.
Вони маленькі, зроблені з мінімуму металу.
Дрони не лише ведуть розвідку.
Українські розробки "Кажан" і "Вампір" можуть нести і скидати боєприпаси.
Один з найбільш загадкових безпілотників - "Бобер".
Про нього відомо небагато.
Це дрон-камікадзе великої дальності.
Саме такі безпілотники не раз вражали цілі в Москві.
Також в Україні з'явилося чимало власних FPV-дронів - "з видом від першої особи".
Наприклад, це коптери "Пегас".
З липня 2022 року Україна будує свою "Армію дронів".
Це урядовий проєкт. У його рамках держава закуповує іноземні й українські БПЛА для війська.
Георгій Цхакая був одним з ініціаторів цього проєкту.
Результати, на мою думку, дуже хороші.
Ми зменшили бюрократію, створили "податкову гавань" для дронів, прибрали всі ввізні мита.
Дозволили виробникам дронів стати частиною "Дія Сіті", що дає їм податкові стимули.
95 відсотків усіх українських дронів - розробки приватних компаній.
Але до FPV-безпілотників долучилися й три державні підприємства.
Ми як держава так само приєдналися до цієї історії, виготовляємо.
До кінця року - тисячі і більше ми на загал сказати не можемо.
Досягнення України у виробництві БПЛА за останні два роки фахівці й урядовці називають "стрибком" уперед.
Ми збільшили виробництво дронів у 100 разів.
Можливо, у 150 разів у деяких випадках, а можливо й більше.
Ми починали війну з "Байрактаром" і все.
Зараз в нас виробництв, взяті на озброєння офіційно на літо, станом на літо 28 дронів,
з них 9 дронів-камікадзе, про які ми взагалі не знали, що це таке.
На фронті Росія використовує розвідувальні безпілотники "Орлан" і ударні "Ланцети".
Ці дрони часто працюють в парі.
За останній рік вони стали одними з найефективніших БПЛА армії РФ.
Те, чим Росія обстрілює цивільне населення України,
вивчають фахівці Київського національно-дослідного інституту судових експертиз.
Основа роботи, те, що дошкуляє Україні, - це "шахед" перед вами.
Безпілотники, марковані літерою "М" виготовлялися в Ірані.
Кілька місяців тому з'явилися нові.
Є "шахеди" з буквою "К". "Герань-2" тут написано.
"К021" - це з першої партії. Це вже російської збірки "шахед".
Власне російських деталей у дронах, вироблених в РФ, небагато.
Це найпростіші компоненти. Решту Росія купує в Ірані, Китаї та… на Заході.
Це карбюратор від нього. Написано ось - "мейд ін Ірланд".
Ірландці випускають. Він що на мотокосилку, що… Загального призначення.
Бізнес є бізнес. Одні виробляють, інші купують,
це не продукція військового призначення.
Система управління, навігаційна система, система наведення, блок управління польотом, інерційна система -
майже всі електронні компоненти з усього світу.
Тобто відомі західні компанії зі США, європейські, японські, корейські.
Дослідники визнають: "шахед" - вдала розробка.
Такої ж думки і авіаційний експерт Валерій Романенко.
Там прекрасна аеродинаміка, там летюче крило інтегральної такої конструкції,
тобто фюзеляж теж є, інтегральне компонування,
яка дозволяє в мінімальному об'ємі містити максимум палива і вибухівки.
Я вважаю, що цього цілком достатньо для того, щоб зробити реінженіринг,
просто його тупо скопіювати, використати ті самі двигуни. А нам потрібні великі дрони.
Експерти вважають дрони-камікадзе й особливо далекобійні ударні дрони
однією зі слабких сторін України.
Чому у України немає власного "шахеда"?
А чому ми думаємо, що його немає?
Так коротко і без деталей відповідає Ярослав Олійник -
військовослужбовець, аеророзвідник, радник мінстратегрому.
Він допомагає уряду визначити найбільш перспективні українські розробки.
Ми, напевно, не "країна-ксерокс", тому що ми не можемо взяти все, що хочемо,
і скопіювати з-за кордону, тому що так не можна, так неправильно.
Але ми сильніші в розумі, ми самі придумаємо.
А експерти-дослідники російських дронів нагадують:
що "шахеди", що російські "Орлани" розробляються вже багато років.
Іран уже давно під санкціями і там державна програма по БПЛА уже кілька десятиліть працює.
Досягли певних успіхів. Але теж брали аналоги, копії.
Ми хочемо, щоб за півтора року війни у нас все уже було. Це дуже важко.
В "Укроборонпромі" заявляють, що Україна вже створила не просто аналог "шахеда",
а навіть більш потужні моделі з дальністю польоту близько тисячі кілометрів.
Утім деталі таких розробок не розкриваються.
Так само невідомо, наскільки масовим є їхнє виробництво.
Виробники БПЛА кажуть: усе більше складників для дронів виробляються в Україні.
Але деталі й механізми, які треба завезти, не можуть замовити заздалегідь.
Усе через те, що держава "не думає" на рік вперед.
Заздалегідь замовляти по спрощеній процедурі ми можемо тільки якщо у нас є контракт.
Держава підписує контракти з виконанням три-чотири місяці, не на рік.
Тобто на наступний рік ми не можемо зараз підписати контракти, бо не визначена потреба від держави.
Але при цьому закупати, щоб задовольнити контракти, нам треба заздалегідь.
Відповідно по спрощеній процедурі ми не можемо наповнити склад.
Також є брак кадрів. Чимало фахівців виїхали за кордон, пішли в армію.
Або - на інші проєкти, адже виробників БПЛА в Україні нині - десятки.
Валерій Романенко вважає велику кількість різних виробників проблемою.
Зокрема, у створенні ударних дронів.
На думку експерта, держава розпорошує зусилля.
Нам поки що не вдається, так би мовити, створити, вибрати один-два єдиних дрони
і випускати їх масово, щоб всі, хто роблять варіації на тему ударного дрона,
вибрали найкращий варіант, цей найкращий варіант доповнили своїми вдалими елементами цього дрону
і таким чином створити єдиний дрон, який можна буде випускати масово.
Утім урядовці такий підхід вважають неправильним.
На їхню думку, вільна конкуренція та винахідливість -
сильна сторона української "армії дронів".
Філософія росіян полягає в тому, що вони роблять щось одне.
Наша філософія в тому, що ми відкриваємо ринок.
Це привносить додаткові інновації та ідеї.
Ми не можемо перемогти Росію у традиційний спосіб.
Нам потрібно бути більш інноваційними. Конкуренція створює інновації.
У нас більш якісні вироби, ми перші придумуємо або вигадуємо нові засоби, нову тактику застосування.
Ми першими почали скидати боєприпаси з "мавіків", що було популярно в 2022 році.
Тобто ми сильніші в розумі і ми завжди щось вигадуємо.
В уряді певні: українські виробники БПЛА мають шанс вийти на провідні позиції у світі.
Адже нині українські розробки постійно вдосконалюються
і одразу проходять випробування у суворих умовах - на справжній війні.